les bateaux il déjà gâté tout il y a les
gens Mme qui sont tombés dans l'eau tu
vois donc moi aussi j'avais peur parce
que il y a personne je connais personne
dans le bateau donc je me dis si moi si
moi jeis tombé dans je vais faire
comment pour m' sorti et puis en plus
c'est pas un enu tu vois donc c j était
choqué donc pleuré j'ai pleuré fatigué
jusqu'à monux même c'est devenu rouge tu
vois attends attends je vais voir voilà
ouais ici on me voit ici c'est diplôme
des piscine que on a reu CCI sur plus
des tr/4 des jeunes on a des jeunes à la
fin qui savent nager pour la majorité on
peut dire qu'on a a des jeunes qui
savent se sauver il voit aussi surtout
l'eau comme une source plus
d'épanouissement corporel et plus comme
une source de peur et de crainte comme
ils ont pu le voir dans le
[Musique]
passé au au début quand je nangeais dans
l'eau le souvenir me rattrape tu vois
même je suis arrivé ici pour dormir seul
dans la chambre il y avait un peu
j'étais pasqu tranquille dans la tête tu
vois maintenant l'eau je peux m'en
sortir tu vois même si je veux pas tenir
longtemps si je suis tombé dans un lot
je sais que je peux me débrouiller un
peu il peut tenir un peu tu vois si je
vis quelqu'un il se Noy dans l'eau je
peux faire mon mieux pour le sauver il
peux faire je suis fier de moi bien je
suis fieron c'est comme
ça
revenir à Marseille revenir au bord de
la Méditerranée c'est compliqué pour une
grande majorité des jeunes c'est
compliqué parce que c'est quand même
cette mer qui a été une source
d'angoisse plus ou moins grande pour
certains donc c'est travaillé vraiment
en amont à travers les groupes de
paroles on est aussi une équipe
d'adultes qui est très nombreux sur sé
jour pour justement pouvoir prendre des
temps individuel avec eux et leur
permettent tranquillement de
pouvoir reprendre un petit peu contact
avec la
Méditerranée je suis nagé
j'ai fait le sous-marin en bas ouais
c'est nouveau Ousman quand Mme et parce
que maintenant si je voulais je vais
aller seul avec meses mes amis
passer comme des weekends à la piscine
le projet àrois rouge m'a aidé à effacer
beaucoup de
choses sur la Méditerranée K
[Musique]
viik